it was the 1976 film all the president's
men that made impeachment kind of sexy
it lionized the journalists who chased
down a president's lies Burstein got
another source I just confirmed does any
job we gonna run it tomorrow you don't
have to the story sell it for sure but
it's just got off the phone with gold
okay we go with it
but today the roles are reversed aren't
they and it's the journalists and the
Democrats spinning the lies and they
aren't doing it very well now for
brevity's sake tonight we're going to
focus on only five lies that the media
and the Democrats have told in their
quixotic quest to remove the president
from office the first whopper and it's a
clever tactic state your warped opinion
repeat it and then repeat it again and
again and again and then claim it's a
fact the facts are uncontested the
president abused his power for his own
personal political benefit at the
expense of our national security the
facts before us are undisputed the
evidence is already overwhelming and the
facts are really not contested contested
that is very very clever
of course the facts are contested you're
trying to pass off your opinions and
your suppositions and your presumptions
as facts that's not how it goes not when
you want to remove a president from
office the next lie is their claim that
they're not enjoying every stinking
minute of this impeachment push we don't
take any Glee in this at all it's
heartbreaking we do not take this
lightly we are charged with a sober and
somber responsibility no I have expected
Jackson lay right there to say and I'd
like to thank the Academy and my agent
for this award the bad acting
these people are total frauds
Shh do you hear that it's it's Nancy and
the squad clinking champagne glasses on
Instagram
the third lie this has nothing and I
mean nothing to do with 2020 this has
nothing to do with politics and
everything to do with defending our
republic and our Constitution a lot of
us feel this way it's not political the
Democratic districts and the president
carry who we consulted all some of them
absolutely nothing to do with politics
it wasn't about politics partisanship
nothing nice try Nancy now just five
minutes before that pronouncement of
hers she said this but I do think the
aha moment for the country was a
credible report from a whistleblower the
polls went from 59 opposed to
impeachment 34 in favor - it - aha now
the fourth lie by pursuing impeachment
we the Democrats are channeling the
founders the founders feared the return
of a monarchy in America we sit here
with a duty to the founders to fulfill
their wisdom the founders expressed fear
their president could subvert our
democracy the founders worried about
just this type of abuse of power now
maybe they're talking about the founders
of I don't know the ACLU or Soros and
the gang at the Open Society Foundations
that maybe that was founders yeah
definitely and by the way I too can go
to brainy quote calm and type in Madison
Jefferson J and the word impeachment and
also come up with random quotes that
kind of support what I think most likely
though the framers would be horrified at
the entire state of the Democrat Party
to say nothing of this ridiculous sprint
to a presidential takedown and finally
the fifth and most glaring obvious lie
Democrats they're still agonizing over
how they'll actually vote on impeachment
I think that I'd want to reserve
judgment on that I'm going to reserve
any kind of a public judgement I really
have to reserve judgment or at least
expressing that general okay yeah I'm
sure Nadler Schiff and Pelosi are
pouring over the Fiona Hill Alexander
Veneman transcripts tonight and they're
parsing every word of the Trump
szalinski transcript now when he said do
us a favor did he really mean do me a
favor had him the truth is Nancy Pelosi
lost control of her caucus in late
summer when the venal thinking of Schiff
and the squad prevailed that this
president had to go that's what they
thought in their heart of hearts they
could not risk the possibility of his
being reelected in 2020 can't trust the
people to vote for him
they might just vote him in back into
office reelect him for another four
years so they had to move to impeach him
was whatever they had a grab bag a
potpourri of of ridiculous ideas charges
suppositions
even if it was based on hearsay
conjecture and yes lies
if Pelosi Nadler and shift took their
duty the Constitution and the country
seriously they would have told the
radicals to let the voters decide but
don't worry in 11 short months they will
and that's the angle